la première chose que j'aimerais dire à
toutes les personnes qui nous regardent
ce soir toutes les victimes de violence
qui nous regardent ce soir le débat
qu'on va avoir il peut il peut être
lourd il peut être compliqué donc sachez
la première chose que j'aimerais dire
c'est sachez que vous n'êtes pas seuls
si vous avez besoin d'être vous pouvez
appeler le 39 19 c'est un numéro gratuit
et anonyme qui est disponible 24 heures
sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 donc la première
chose que je dis à toutes ces personnes
là si vous n'êtes pas seuls ensuite la
deuxième chose que j'aimerais dire c'est
on vous croit nation vous croire
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui en france
la plupart des victimes de violences
sexuelles voient leurs paroles remise en
cause et c'est pas normal alors c'est
vrai que c'est ce qu'on s'est vraiment
le leitmotiv on vous croit ouais on vous
croit parce que ce qui se passe c'est
que il ya beaucoup de jeunes filles ou
john holmes qui ont du mal à pousser la
porte d'un commissariat avant a poussés
à aller eux-mêmes en parler à ses
proches à ses parents parce qu'ils
disent on va pas me croire et le truc
que vous dites à chaque fois ci on vous
croit donc c'est en ça que vous avez été
aussi
gêné par les paroles de bernard qui je
pense bernard je vous dis qui s'est mal
exprimé juste lui il s'est dit
maintenant je pense qu'il s'est dit je
voulais juste devant mon ami tu devrais
tout à fait d'accord et ce qu'elle dit
d'accord non mais sur sur la raison vous
avez entièrement raison et moi même je
travaille là dessus qu'est ce que vous
lui reprochez fondation des femmes sur
ce qu'il a dit c'est sexy oui qu'est-ce
que
je parlais mademoiselle je parlais par
don was i je veux parler de présomption
d'innocence jeudi harry est mon ami j
jusqu'à ce qu'on me prouve le contraire
qui a fait quelque chose de mal
évidemment je pense à la présumée
victime tout le monde est présumé
coupable ou présumées victimes c'est
parole contre parole donc pour le moment
on n'a rien prouvé je le soutiens c'est
mon ami je suis désolé cette affaire est
évidemment et si c'est vrai c'est
épouvantable je pense à la victime je
m'occupe de ça aussi un peu vous savez
je l' ai dit l'autre jour un peu
légèrement pour pas insisté je vous
comprends et vous avez raison ce que je
n'ai pas aimé en revanche c'est que izia
musique elle a balancé ça sur sa mère
que j'avais reçu à l'époque il ya 30 ans
si vous voulez mais si on peut le voir
ce serait génial parce que là la culture
du vial nord-mali viola ça me choque
alors alors je vous dis parce qu'il ya
cette chose on met les gens on va revoir
là dessus parce qu'il n'y avait pas la
culture des recettes et à cette vidéo
qui est sorti
depuis quelques jours c'est cette vidéo
qui tourne sur vous bernard montiel
archives de 1989 et d'interviews d'aziz
akin la merde izia et gilot mais pas par
bernard montiel dans l'émission la une
est à vous sur tf1 qui refait surface et
qui refait scandale qui fait scandale
d'ailleurs ce qu'elle est partie
scandale à l'époque on a la vidéo
regardez c'était à lisa d'ailleurs va me
retrouver à 10 à elle est très très
jolie venez venez mon petit bonjour est
très jolie teinte et asseyez vous mettra
très joli bond vous est toujours très
difficile ce genre d'interview dans ces
cas là voilà vous êtes là bon c'est
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de rire excusez
moi aziza vous êtes très joli merci
bonjour c'est pratique pour chanter
aussi le dites moi vous venez d'où tunis
tunisie dites moi chez vous les fermes
en général sont plus voilé que c'est un
an
ah non ça c'est fini le coût des voiles
non parce que moi je suis plutôt
parisiennes aussi non je voulais faire
remarquer ici pardon je voulais faire
remarquer aussi que vous aviez un très
joli décolleté
cette vidéo qui reçoivent alors je
serais content quand l'airbus alors
dites-nous alors je voulais vous dire
pourquoi le coût du voile moi même je me
suis posé la question pourquoi j'ai
parlé du voile très mauvaise interview 1
ça c'est clair ce n'est pas beau c'est
la nasa mais zéro est là c'est là qu'on
voyage étaient mes amis d'ailleurs je
veux dire
enfin quoiqu'il en soit très mauvaise
interview je reconnais j'ai en moi qui
produisent un vous que j'ai été séduit
par cette femme avec laquelle je me suis
très bien entendu d'ailleurs puisque en
sortant on s'est embrassés on s'est
salués etc c'est une femme formidable a
été délicieuse sa chanson était top
c'est une chanson qui date de 1981 mais
ce important de l'aveyron alors pourquoi
voici pourquoi j'ai parlé du voile
simplement parce que la tunisie venait
d'interdire le voile à cette année là
donc je trouve ça un terrain intéressant
pour cette femme qui est d'origine
tunisienne d'en parler sauf
qu'évidemment après bon on est parti sur
autre chose alors il ya la fille jada
site là n'est pas le débat je vois la
fida tentant de le priver non mais là on
va au là il ya la fille d'assises à
kindia gill qui a fait un post quand je
vois dire sur tpb tv il ya quelques mois
que ton ami ppda est juste un gros
lourdaud puis hier soir toujours sur tes
pmp décidément quelle belle émission car
les habitants est vraiment une fille
formidable je pense toujours à cette
super interview que tu as fait de ma
maman fin 80 love you mahmoud voilà donc
c'est bien mais je comprends qu'un
défendre sa mère il ya est une très
belle artiste la fille mais c'est pas ça
l'histoire je suis quand même très
choquée que qu'est ce qui est choquant
dans ce que j'ai dit c'est de la
maladresse j'étais nul qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous en pensez de ça
parce que j'ai dit qu'elle était très
belle j'étais troublé par sa beauté
c'est vrai je dis qu'elle un décolleté
il ya trente ans un excuse rien vu
géraldine moi je les dis à bernard je
trouve que globalement c'est vrai que
l'interview est catastrophique il est
très maladroit était pas à la botte est
pas au bon endroit tapas t'as pas les
bonnes questions nappes sont que tu es
là sans être là tu es un peu perche
était un peu ailleurs donc oui trop
catastrophique après une fois qu'on a
dit que c'est une interview rater
complètement à côté de la plaque à
l'époque personne s'en est offusqué donc
c'est très compliqué de regarder
mademoiselle avec les lunettes les yeux
de 2021 c'est lui quelque chose qui
s'est passé il ya 30 ans c'est pas c'est
pas pour autant qu'aujourd'hui il
faudrait faire ça de la même manière
mais moi je pense que pour autant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors on visionne
toutes les émissions télé dia 40 depuis
40 ans et on demande des têtes et on dit
ah non là monsieur vous n'aviez pas
droit à non là c'était c'était bordeaux
là ça va pas mal moi je pense qu'il faut
éduquer les gens il faut leur dire que
ça c'est pas possible il faut qu'on
apprenne il faut faire de la pédagogie
mais voilà c'est très compliqué malgré
tout de juger trente ans après voyez
parce qu'en fait ça se faisait quant aux
parents qu'il y avait chez pas la
playmate avant le journal de 20h ça se
faisait aujourd'hui ce serait pas
possible quand il y avait 15 bourg qui
traitait catherine ringer de [ __ ] ben
voilà c'est choquant et denisot disais
rien et se marrer et igloo c'est donc
voilà il ya plein il ya plein de choses
choquantes et et malgré tout dans moi je
comprends votre combat est légitime et
c'est formidable tout ce que vous avez
fait par rapport au théâtre et ce à
moins que ça est vraiment on est
vraiment derrière nous mais c'est très
très compliqué de découper les têtes
malgré tout avec s'il vous plaît
j'aimerais d'abord qu'on revienne sur
les propos de bernard qui vous ont
choqué parce que ça part de là on est on
est déjà passé à la deuxième partie il
ya eu des propos dans tpp qui vous ont
choqué qui vous ont
embêtés on peut comprendre qu est ce que
vous avez à dire à bernard ce soir sur
ses propos déjà alors déjà tous les
choses qu'on dit ce sont pas des combats
ce sont des idées les femmes ont des
idées pas que des combats ensuite les
propos qui ont choqué et pourquoi cette
interview d'il ya 30 ans 40 ans ressort
aujourd'hui c'est parce que les poulets
propos que vous dites sont les mêmes
aujourd'hui la problématique est la même
la problématique c'est que vous vous en
faites vous être la promotion de la
culture du viol quand vous ça et
pourtant c'est ce que vous faites
monsieur quand tu quand vous dites quand
vous dites d'arrêt habitants que c'est
votre pote qu'un d'onet que c'est oui
certes mais sauf qu'en fait tout le
monde tout le monde ici dans la salle
présomption d'innocence où ça n'existera
pas de présomption de la science la
présente son innocence je l'aide quand
on me demande de sort des mandats mais
dans un pays en france qui soutient la
présomption d'innocence en revanche là
tout le monde dans la salle connais
quelqu'un qui a été violé mais personne
ne connaît de violeurs il est où le
problème il est où le problème c'est
quand vous le condamnez avant que je
sois juge ce que vous êtes en train de
dire que je suis à moi je soutiens votre
combat je vous assure vous avez réseau
with elephants que les choses changent
et c'est la première est venue alors ce
que je suis en train de dire c'est que
les propos que vous dites les propos que
vous tenez ils ont des conséquences sur
la société tout entière en fait lorsque
lorsque vous dites que que qu'un mec et
qu'un mec qui violent est un mec qui est
honnête un mec à vous savez vous qu'il
avait réuni 1 ce qui n'est jamais dit ça
voyez comme
les extraire poser problème regarder
tout ça vous savez tous ces gens qui
sont sous couvert d'anonymat ça mais ça
vous a touché quand même oui parce que
c'était une telle violence surtout ceux
qui n'ont pas compris ils ont même
déformé mes propos je moi je pensais à
la victime présumée c'est d'abord à el
akel je pense évidemment si c'est vrai
seulement c'est mon ami moi je souhaite
à tout le monde de défendre ses amis
comme ça jusqu'au bout je le défendrai
temps qu'on m'a pas prouvé le contraire
maintenant s'ils s'estiment en amitié et
trahi par harry ce que je ne crois pas
je ne le crois pas toujours pas c'est
pas possible voilà c'est tout ce que
j'ai à dire là dessus moi je peux vous
dire qu'évidemment je n'y crois pas à
cette histoire moi je le défends parce
que je connais son avis je sais je suis
en vie je sais comment il est et quel
rapport il avec les femmes il est
toujours extrêmement correct c'est un
mec archi honnête vraiment donc je ne
crois pas à cette histoire voilà le
souffle et je défends mon amitié avec
avec harris est un ami et je lui
resterait fidèle mais ce que je défends
surtout c'est la présomption d'innocence
évidemment sueur et larmes et maintenant
on me met carrément bernard montiel
hashtag culture du viol
s'il ya un paquet de tarés h et la
culture de l'amitié alors marie on à
séoul elle a donc laissé l'appareil
alors allez-y donc là
où j'ai dit que ce qui vous diront les
propos qui sont graves là dans ce que
vous dites c'est que vous parlez de
quelqu'un qui est mise en cause pour
viol donc la justice fait son travail il
ya la présomption d'innocence tous et
toutes d'accord là dessus ce soir sauf
qu'en fait les propos que vous tenez ils
ont des répercussions sur l'ensemble de
la société lorsque vous dites de
quelqu'un qui est mise en cause pour
viol que vous ne vous ne croyez pas à
cette histoire parce que vous êtes ton
parc parce que vous êtes son ami parce
que je le connais en fait oui très bien
mais en fait les ça veut dire que vous
défendez le viol sauf quand c'est vos
amis et non alors vous êtes sûr qu'il
l'a violée alors métro mais dans un rôle
non mais attendez attendez attendez
bernard marie lys qui avoue ce qu'elle
vous ce qu'elle vous ce cas vous
reproche marie dit je lis voilà il faut
il faut aussi se dire qui a été une
présumée victime parce que j'en ai dit
tout de suite mais non mais faut pas
l'oublier mais j'ai oublié j'en ai parlé
tout de suite non mais c'était en mai
ccc le soldat mais ça l'est dit tout de
suite c'est qu'il l'a présumés riches
parce qu'il faut retirer je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous c'est je ne
crois pas à cette histoire parce que là
on sort du rapport amical ou ligne à le
faire dans la c'est assez dur c'est le
nom et berna jeu encore une fois je vous
défends aujourd'hui ce que je voudrais
dire quand même c'est qu'avec bernard la
beauce et toute la journée sur les deux
affaires il est totalement impartial la
chose vraiment je sème un journal c'est
on a passé la journée tous les deux
plein de coups de téléphone et ibos
maladie veut savoir ce qui s'est passé
mais à cette phrase elle est maladroite
mais après moi le sable assure bernard
montiel c'est un journaliste un
chroniqueur c'est quelqu'un de bien sûr
est tout à fait bien de tout à fait
enfin honnête et la ja le dérapage là
dessus mais en faire une cible de votre
courrier victime geste allait de lâcher
la meute en plus je vais vous dire vous
savez quoi j'ai aimé tout ce que vous
avez dit jusqu'à présent et je suis
d'accord avec vous sur ce héros fait ça
c'est pas une cible le premier c'est
quand il avait lâché le match c'est
quand même atteint c'est que j'ai bloqué
mon installation été tenus ce jour
compte en tout ce sont des propos que
l'on retrouve dans l'ensemble de la
sphère publique est ce que vous savez ce
que c'est la culture du viol la culture
du viol c'est que dans l'ensemble de la
société que ce soit à la machine à café
que ce soit au travail que ce soit dans
les médias que ce soit à la télé partout
dans l'ensemble de cette sphère publique
il ya des propos qui minimisent qui
banalise qui n'y voir qui encourage le
viol c'est ce que j'ai fait moi oui oui
quand vous dites des quelques banalisée
jean trois lionnes quand vous dites ça
je n'accepte que vous ne croyez pas dire
vous ne croyez pas les phases amis où
ils allaient souvent soit attaquée sur
nier ce que vous feriez l'extrémité car
pour un ami qu'est ce que vous feriez
jusqu'à présent il n'est pas il n'est
pas condamné on n'y a aucune preuve pour
le moins présomption d'innocence un peu
d'humanité mais là quand elle est tout
le monde ce n'est pas vous à madame et
en général on condamne tout le monde moi
je vois j'entends tout le monde me dit
tu as tu es sûre vers là on n'est sûr de
rien et comme je les dis si mon amitié
trahie c'est évident que je serai blessé
se serait blessé évidemment mais pour le
moment c'est un ami c'est un mec je
connais je n'y crois pas toujours défini
et j'espère me tromper d'avoir exemple
non